pas d en faire le beau gosse je dis tout
haut si je dis tout ici jeux balades
c'est mathieu j'ai eu tous les
téléspectateurs non mathieu joue lundi
sans les loges stade à titre la tat sur
la venu le coeur ouvert à l'inconnu le
chien aurait là qu'est ce qu'on dit
mathieu et en main je lui va très bien
le farfadet une meuf lafare fadel très
bien mais on m'a dit tu la connais il
paraît qu'il m'arrive taper show pop up
mais je dirais non
on est ici pour faire de la musique et
des pâtes tu fais pas de pub à moi avoue
mathieu enfin j'espère qu'on parle de
pauline juste on mettre en avant c'est
juste une affiche collée
aucune preuve comme quoi j'ai dépêché
moi je voulais juste que ça se mette en
avant parce qu'en fait je suis dos au
filet du but juste un prétexte
c'est le lot avec les animaux mais
mathieu dit voilà c'est quoi bon on fait
alors vous n'allez pas faire la nouvelle
star ce soir vous allez faire ce break
vous vous retournez vous voir et vous me
dites juste je vous posais une question
m'est témoin de musique domine de
suspense de mystère et vous allez me
dire d'auto oui ou non face mathieu
c'est ce que vous allez faire si c'est
oui ou vous retourner si ces noms vous
restez vous restez vous voit de dos
pendant toute l'émission vous aurez
affaire à l'avoir pêchons mathieu est ce
que vous avez pécho poly9 la nouvelle
star le métro
ça veut dire il n'a pas mis d'aaland
binaire
aulas
voilà
là
bien sûr nous at on pas ensemble mais je
dis rien je sais même pas si c'est vrai
non mais là c'est sûr qu'il a péché à
chaque fois fait pour impôts donc c'est
fait vous avez raison vous avez bien
raison les crises et les trois maisons
où elle est très mignonne et vous fait
un très joli couple voilà je vous le dis
bravo
j'ai la même question
mathieu je suis un peu ému là mais tout
à l'heure on parlait de ce qui s'est
passé de ce truc là des émotions chez
s'est pas tu l'as vue qui vu quoi mon
cul